[Music]
did you hear that hazel this is my
chance to prove I'm just as good as any
stinking reindeer meat Elliot come on
Elliot oh he's a miniature horse i
partly broke 15 seconds hundred twenty
seventh time's the charm with big dreams
if you just give me a chance I know I'd
have a shot at make me stay at this team
I just know it ladies and goats is why
Santa always you stay here this holiday
season this is where reindeer become
heroes boys hey Little League tryouts
we're last week small fry I'll never
give up
get used to it stranger are jerks
they've always been jerks and they
always will be jerks even Sam
understands that Santa
[Applause]
[Music]
if you follow your heart big dreamers
dreamed big knees
try it again you can do anything
the guy's got some move featuring the
voice talents of Josh Hutcherson
Samantha P with Martin Short and Martin
Short Morena Baccarin Jeff Dunham and
John Cleese start out with embarrass me
[Music]
we've got each other that's what counts
[Music]
big dreamers dream big Elliot the
littlest reindeer coming to select movie
theaters nationwide for one day only
Saturday December 1st tickets on sale
now at the littlest reindeer calm
[Music]